my neighbor totoro is directed by Hayao
Miyazaki and I just got to see this in
theaters there's a really cool thing
going on this year called Ghibli fest
fathom events is doing a special
two-night only run of various Studio
Ghibli films and Totoro is the first one
they show it's a good excuse for me to
finally review it because one of my
goals for my channel is to have a review
for every Studio Ghibli film ever made
at some point in the future I'd like to
have that accomplished it's going to
take a while trust me but this year I'm
going to try to knock out all the ones
they're showing at Ghibli fest despite
the fact that I know many of you have
seen this movie I'm also sure a lot of
you haven't so I'm going to avoid
spoilers in this review basically it's
about two young girls and a father who
moved to a rural countryside in a new
house and they explore the house and
they make up stories about the fact that
they think it's haunted
and these their imagination they're
clearly two very happy-go-lucky girls
and their mother is in the hospital it's
unclear exactly what she has there are
small hints given towards what their
mother's illness might be but it's never
really clearly stated and it's clear as
an adult watching this movie that these
kids are using their imagination so much
because they're trying to escape the
fear that they have about whether or not
their mother could die and eventually
the youngest girl May while her sisters
at school runs into a beast named Totoro
in the forest
now Totoro has a lot of magical
abilities he can make plants grow it
will in fact entire trees he has a cat
bus at his disposal that can basically
take you anywhere that you want to go
and he can fly on a spinning top is he
in the girl's imagination or is he real
can he actually break through the real
world or is he just an imaginary friend
one of my biggest fears and I mean this
for real is that classic films will not
be appreciated by new generations I'm
afraid that some of these great classic
animations are going to be tossed aside
by a new generation that just wants 3d
computer animation and a lot of dance
sequences in their animated films and I
was so refreshed and relieved to sit in
this theater today surrounded by kids
who were in awe at this movie
normally I'm annoyed when kids get
really vocal during films but here it
was perfect
and all the right moments kids were like
wow
all I see Totoro like they were so into
it and I was so relieved to see that
because this movie has none of the
modern distractions of almost every kids
movie that's released today
there's no breathtaking action sequences
there's no explosions it's not in 3d and
it's not computer animated but the kids
in this theater were transfixed by this
movie and so was I it still works
beautifully as an adult the animation is
just so damn good and this movie is
going to be timeless seeing it in
theaters today and feeling the audience
react at all the right moments this
movie is going to be around for a really
long time and I could not be happier
because it deserves to be
Hayao Miyazaki is just so frickin
brilliant I can't give this guy enough
praise and as I review the Studio Ghibli
films throughout this year you're going
to hear this a lot but I can't escape
saying it their animations are just the
best there is I think they're the best
in the entire industry they've been
around for so long and I hope that they
continue to make films in the future and
they can figure out a way to work out
their financial issues because we need
films like this that inspire children's
imaginations that can make adults think
also about the film because you can look
at this so and be like them for the
first half of it Totoro seems to appear
when one of them is asleep does that
mean that he's just in their dreams but
then as the film progresses you can see
that other things are happening while
they're awake so not only is the
animation gorgeous and the characters a
lot of fun it's a film that actively
uses your brain you feel like you're
engaged with the way it's cut together
with the direction and you feel like
you're using your imagination just like
these kids are it captures I think
perfectly the carefree adventurous
feeling that so many kids have the score
also by Joe Hisaishi is one of his best
and I mean I'm saying things you've
heard a million times over and over
again but it has to be said this
animation is just so beautiful
it also sneaks up on you because at one
point the film gets a little serious and
I haven't seen this movie in a while and
I was surprised at how invested I
actually got which tells you just really
what Miyazaki was doing
in the first two acts of this movie
because yes you're experiencing a very
fun and sort of light movie until you
realize that you actually really care
about these characters and that's rare
in animation I'm going to give my
neighbor totoro a much deserved a-plus
thank you so much guys for watching I'm
going to try to see every film they're
showing this year and review them for
you guys and since I am wearing this
shirt yes Samurai Jack season 5 gave me
everything I wanted it was so so good
you guys are the best thank you so much
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get steppen
eyes
[Music]